laissez moi vous dire cette journée a
été très longue les ça me dérange pas de
retourner à l'intérieur de la maison
alors soyez respectueux ici d'accord
vous m'avez entendu merci
omar va vous adresser la parole
vous pouvez également lui poser
certaines questions si les questions
deviennent dépendants du genre de
question je vais arrêter les choses et
on retournera à l'intérieur de la maison
c'est la première fois qu omar sort
depuis qu'il a 15 ans alors omar sur
quelque chose à dire
eh bien j'aimerais remercier les cours
pour avoir m'avoir fait confiance et
m'avoir libéré
j'aimerais remercier mes avocats les
familles
ma famille toutes les personnes qui
travaillent si fort depuis si longtemps
et j'aimerais remercier le public
canadien pour m'avoir fait confiance et
m'avoir donné une chance c'est ça
prendra peut-être un certain temps mais
je vais vous prouver que je suis plus
que ce qu'on la pensait de moi merci
beaucoup
omar que voulez-vous que les canadiens
sachent à votre sujet et bien qu'on me
donne l'opportunité de voir qui je suis
en tant que personne et non pas
seulement en tant que l'on est ensuite
ils pourront juger
qui êtes vous en tant que personne et
bien je prends encore à mon sujet je
suis encore en croissance
je crois l'apprentissage je n'ai pas eu
beaucoup d'expérience dans la vie et je
suis très emballé de pouvoir commencer
ma vie
que voulez-vous faire de plus ah c'est
une question difficile tout rien en
particulier mais tous inaudible
eh bien j'aimerais dire que je suis
désolé pour la douleur que j'ai
peut-être causé aux familles des
victimes
il n'y a rien que je puisse faire par
rapport au passé mais j'espère que le
futur que je pourrais faire des choses
pour le futur
comment vous sentez vous en ce moment eh
bien je suis encore sous un état de choc
je suis heureux mais je crois que je
vais peut-être cracher un peu plus tard
mais en ce moment je suis encore un
joueur encore très contrôlée questions
anodines rien jusqu'à maintenant je suis
très surpris c'est la liberté bien
meilleure que je ne le croyais et le
public canadien jusqu'à maintenant a été
bien meilleure que je leur ait anticipé
pourriez vous nous dire ce que vous avez
fait cet après midi et bien nous sommes
sales et dîner et ensuite il a fallu
retourner à la cour pour signer des
documents
j'étais surpris par rapport à certaines
des shérifs ils ont vraiment été très
sympathiques avec moi parce que nous
avons été là quand même assez longtemps
à tout le monde a été très sympathique
question inaudible terminer mon
éducation
j'ai beaucoup de choses à apprendre j'ai
beaucoup de compétences de base à
acquérir alors un jour à la fois y aller
lentement n'ont malheureusement pas
question inaudible enfin c'est quand
même bien je dois dire c'est très bien
l'avez-vous quoi que ce soit dire à
monsieur harper
et bien je vais devoir le décevoir je
suis une meilleure personne qui ne le
croit
il y a des voisins ici qui sont là pour
vous souhaiter la bienvenue
j'ai public bienvenue bienvenus merci
beaucoup de m'avoir hisser et j'ai bien
d'apprendre à vous à mieux vous
connaître assez bien j'ai quelques
problèmes mais ça va bien
y'a de quoi que ce soit qui vous
empêcherait de travail et non non pas
vraiment question inaudible pardon vous
est devenu une personne polarisantes au
canada réponse père je ne peux rien
faire à ce sujet tout ce que je peux
faire c'est travailler sur moi même
c'est vraiment tout ce que je peux faire
oui je m'en rends compte mais je ne le
sens pas entièrement encore pour mieux
vous dire de manière catégorique ray le
reste de la question des bruits oui
celle qu'un non ce n'est pas une chose
que je crois en ce moment je veux
commencer
du début à nouveau il y a trop de belles
choses dans la vie que je veux vivre
vous avez des aspirations de carrière
quelque chose dans le domaine de la
santé
je crois que l'on doit pouvoir avoir de
l'empathie envers les gens qui vivent de
la douleur et moi j'ai vécu la douleur
alors je crois que je peux avoir de
l'empathie pour les gens qui traversent
cela j'espère que je pourrai travailler
dans le domaine de la santé
que pensez vous maintenant de votre père
après toutes ces années
eh bien il ya beaucoup de questions que
je j'aimerais pouvoir poser à mon père
mais comme je l'aï dit je ne peux rien
changer au passé tout ce que je peux
faire c'est de travailler sur le présent
et le futur
tous beaucoup de décisions qu'il a
prises
la raison pour laquelle il nous a ramené
la base beaucoup de questions au sujet
du raisonnement par rapport à ces
décisions de vie question inaudible non
que diriez vous à quelqu'un qui
contemple de devenir un extrémiste et
qui voit votre exemple à vous ce que je
dirai qui que ce soit c'est 2 vous
éduquez ne laissait pas que les émotions
vous contrôler l'éducation est très
importante j'ai remarqué que beaucoup de
gens sans manipuler parce qu'elles ne
sont pas éduqués alors l'éducation est
vraiment très importante
est ce que vous aimez des médias sociaux
c'est une chose qui vous est cher
peut-être mais seulement à un niveau
personnel
encore une dernière question
que dites vous cet homme qui est avec
vous depuis si longtemps
il est un homme incroyable et je
l'apprécié énormément
j'apprécie tout son travail depuis onze
ans je suis au fric
il n'est pas écrit deux mois encore
attendez de voir la facture
ok bon soir souper nous allons manger de
l'agneau
oui oui nous allons souper et il ya des
amis qui ont fait des copines et
d'efforts je suis très heureuse je suis
ravie absolument ravis ça fait longtemps
que nous attendons ce moment un dernier
une dernière parole pour le public
canadien
j'aimerais tout simplement les remercier
et je leur demanderai de 2 me donne une
opportunité et ils seront surpris
merci encore désolé de vous avoir fait
attendre si longtemps je vous souhaite
une bonne soirée